i don't think i asked you last time
the most inappropriately absurd question
we've talked a lot about intelligence uh
but you know the bigger question from
intelligence is of meaning
you know intelligent systems are kind of
goal oriented there's throws optimizing
for goal
if you look at the harder prize actually
i mean there's always there's always a
clean formulation of a goal
but the natural questions for us humans
since we don't know our objective
function is what is the meaning of it
all
so the absurd question is what uh
francois cholae do you think is the
meaning of life
what's the meaning of life yeah that's a
that's a big question
um and i think i can i can you know
give you my answer at least
one of my answers and
so you know the one thing that's uh very
important
uh in understanding who we are is that
everything that makes up uh that makes
up ourselves it makes up
we are even even your most personal
thoughts is not actually your own
right like even your most personal
thoughts are
expressed in words that you did not
invent and are
built on concepts and images
that you did not invent we are very much
uh cultural beings right well we are
made of culture we are not that what
makes us different from animals for
instance right
so we are everything about ourselves is
an echo of the past an echo of people
who lived
uh before us right that's who we are
and in the same way if we
manage to contribute something to
the collective edifice of culture
a new idea maybe a beautiful piece of
music a work of art
a grand theory a new word
maybe um that something
is is going to become a part
of the minds of future humans
essentially
forever so everything we do
creates reports right that propagates
into the future
and i i and that that's in a way this is
this uh
our path to immortality is that
as we contribute things to culture
culture in turn in turn becomes future
humans
and we keep influencing people you know
uh thousands of years from now so
our actions today create reports and
these reports i think basically sum up
the meaning of life like in the same way
that we are
the the sum um
of the interactions between many
different reports that came from our
past
we are ourselves creating reports that
will propagate into the future
and that's why you know we should be
this seems like
perhaps an anything to say but we should
be
kind to others during our time
on earth because every act of kindness
creates reports and
and in reverse every act of violence
also creates reports and you want
you want to carefully choose which kind
of reports you want to create
and you want to propagate into the
future and in your case
first of all beautifully put but in your
case creating ripples into the future
human and future
agi systems yes it's
fascinating all success
i don't think there's a better way to
end it francois as always
for a second time and i'm sure many
times in the future it's been a huge
honor
you know one of the most brilliant
people in the machine learning computer
science
science world again that's a huge honor
thanks for talking today it's been a
pleasure
thanks a lot for having me we appreciate
it
you